what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have a
morning coffee chat okay
i'm basically out of coffee i drink most
of it on my way back but
actually it's chai tea i am cutting back
on the coffee i've been drinking tea
more lately so
i don't know if that's better or worse
but
um today
i'm gonna talk to you guys about
i don't know just like the price of fame
and what comes with fame and like things
that you don't normally think about that
come with it
um
sorry i know this car is really loud
it's my parents car
and i love it i love this it's a bad boy
16 passenger van
but it's not the best for filming
because it gets really hot so i have to
keep the
it on otherwise it's it's too hot in
florida
anyways um
so
let's let's talk about the price of fame
so three months ago i started a youtube
show and
on this youtube show i really like
didn't set out to make it like a super
controversial show
um but my idea was just to talk about
like
red pill concepts so to speak
and and nothing like that crazy like i
was gonna talk about how like
sometimes women prefer toxic men and
like bring on girls to talk about that
and then like
i don't know it just early on the girls
were saying [ __ ] that i felt like was
nonsense and i'm just the type like if i
hear something that i think is full of
[ __ ]
um especially like on my platform i'm
just gonna say something um
so
i started to realize that the more
i don't wanna say conflict but the more
like
people two people that disagree
discussed an idea the better it did on
youtube
and i think it's really important for
people to have like disagreements so i
always tried with my show to be like
respectful and have
like two people that disagreed we can
have a conversation and like we could
still be friends outside of it
um
and
what comes with putting your com your
your opinions on a platform like
everyone has opinions
but when you are so public about your
opinions like
it's really hard at times because
like you have friends that fall out with
you based on like social media that they
could choose not to look at right like
nobody's putting a gun to their head and
making them look at your social media
but
and it's weird because i often times i
think like social media isn't really
reflective of real life like i don't
think that
a social media account
like is like real like for example
it kind of tires my brain at times
because
on what if i'm on social media a lot
like there's so much conflict and it's
like conflict conflict conflict conflict
and in real life there really isn't that
much conflict like if you go to the
store if you go to the gym whatever
people aren't gonna come up and start
arguing with you
um but the bigger you get they actually
kind of start to
um
and
even though like even if you've been
like literally like a nice polite kind
person like
they like people get so angry over this
stuff and it's like a price of fame
and it's interesting because i knew like
that's what it would come with
but
you think that like certain people like
they've always known you're more
conservative they always know you kind
of leaned one way you think that they
won't
um
i don't know it's just it's just crazy
because
to me social media like it's not real
and the fact that like like even fresh
and fit and a lot of those shows that
like thrive off of conflict and i'm open
with you guys about this like they are
looking for the most crazy girls and i'm
telling you as someone who runs a show
like this like they are seeking out
those women
and
the way i look at it as is it's a battle
of ideas and you have to get people on
two extremes to have a battle of ideas
but i'm never gonna say that like the
girls on a show are representative of a
population of women and i think that's
where girls get frustrated when we watch
these shows because i'm like i know i
know a lot of virgins like i i know a
decent amount i know
a lot of girls that don't act like that
but most of those girls don't want to
come on a youtube show like you're just
going to get more crazies
um
but like the price part of the price of
fame is one
you feel really exposed because people
start just looking
for things to discredit you
and you also
how do i put it like
you
you also get jealousy like you get girls
that become
like jealous of you because you've
always had these opinions you've always
had the show but it's like the second
that success comes
that that's when that's when they
that's when they come out the woodwork
and then
the third thing
is you get
your brain like changes and this is
something that i observed with content
creators
before i was really a content creator i
was like gosh
these content creators think everyone's
out to get them when in real life nobody
really says anything to anyone
and i didn't really understand it until
i became a content creator
and it's really hard when
it's like you have people nitpicking
every little thing you do
um
and i i i'm never really going to
complain about that because i signed up
for it and i genuinely believe this is
the best job on earth but i do think it
changes your brain like having all the
conflict like sometimes my head hurts to
be
honest and i don't know why like i'm not
making this video to complain because
i'm so like i am so grateful for you
guys
but
i i just think you don't it's stuff you
don't think about until you get famous
and i'll find myself like we'll be like
me and my friend ally will be like
talking about oh these hoes these felt
like like kidding right partially and
and i realized like in real life like
you don't really have conflict like that
not normally so
it just like
but you have to understand that's what
the internet thrives on and
i don't necessarily think it's a bad
thing because at the end of the day i
think the media is like a battle of
ideas and so
the way i structure my show is i want
people on both sides to be accurately
represented and we take the ideas to the
extreme have a conversation and maybe
people fall on one side or the other but
i think it's really important to have
that conflict and talk to people that
disagree with you so we're not just
stuck in our echo chambers
um but the problem is people will take a
clip of something you said or like quote
you out of context and draw their own
conclusions because
either they're uncomfortable and the
shoe fits or
they they just are
they want to assume bad intent
um
so i don't know this is just a little
insight into like what comes with
success
i i'll i'll never
complain i'm telling you the pros
outweigh the cons this is the best job
on the planet i
wouldn't trade it
but
i just think that i realized my life is
never really going to go back to the way
it was
now that like my opinions are out there
like every time i walk into a room
it's like you're really exposed because
everybody knows your opinions where
normally you used to be able to walk
into a room and nobody knows if you're
conservative nobody knows what you think
so
like they automatically like either like
you or you know
are indifferent towards you where now
when you do that like people
automatically have an opinion on you
and the other thing is with women like
women are very much into group think and
so
if one group of women like has an
opinion like they all form that opinion
and that's why like i i'm more someone
that befriends individual women rather
than groups because
i don't know you just can't really
like group think is real
and that's just kind of how girls are
so
i don't know um
yeah that's
that's all i really got today with my
morning coffee thought um
i love you guys
thank you for the support um again this
is a no way to complain
i am grateful for it i think this is the
best job in the world i've always felt
like my calling is to talk to women
like that is genuinely what i think i
was i was meant to do
but
there's a cost with everything you do in
life and this is just like the cost that
i have to live with
and
yeah so
comment let me know in the comments what
you guys think um don't forget to
subscribe i love you bye